(Music)
We are the tribe that they cannot see
We live on an industrial reservation
We are the Halluci Nation
We have been called the Indians
We have been called Native American
We have been called hostile
We have been called pagan
We have been called militant
We have been called many names
We are the Halluci Nation
We are the human beings
The callers of names cannot see us
but we can see them
We are the Halluci Nation
Our DNA is of earth and sky
Our DNA is of past and future
We are the Halluci Nation
We are the evolution,
the continuation
The Halluci Nation
(Music)
The virus took on many shapes
The bear, the elk, the antelope,
the elephant, the deer
The mineral, the iron, the copper,
the coltan, the rubber
The coffee, the cotton, the sugar
The people
The germ traveled faster than the bullet
They harvest the mountainside,
protect the crops, herd the cattle
The people
The women and children
were separated from the men
They divided us according to the regional
filters of their minds
The violence of arrogance
crawls into the air,
nestles into the geospatial cortex
We are not a conquered people
The compound was on fire
The missionaries never hid
their perspective
Prospectors of land
would rather see us disappear
Recyclable prayers
The people
This is my body which is given for you
This is my blood
We are not a conquered people
(Electronic music and chanting)
I was wakened by my elder brother
The compound was on fire
Awakened by my elder brother
(Music)
The compound was on fire
The Halluci Nation
The human beings
The people
See the spiritual in the natural
Through sense and feeling
Everything is related
All the things of earth
And in the sky have spirit
Everything is sacred
Confronted by the ALie Nation
The subjects and the citizens
See the material religions
Through trauma and numb
Nothing is related
All the things of the earth and in the sky
have energy to be exploited
Even themselves, mining their spirits
into souls sold
Into nothing is sacred
Not even their self
The ALie Nation
Alienation
Ancestors
Live in the DNA
In genetic memory
The evolution of descendants
Human being is our natural identity
Natural identity
is where the power of being
Waits for human recognition
To understand
Not to just know
But to understand sacred
Without religion we evolve
Back into our ancestors
With religion we disappear
Into religious heaven and hell
(Electronic music and chanting)
Human beings
We are human, we are of the earth
(Electronic music and chanting)
Human beings
We are human
We are of the earth
Our bone, flesh, blood,
metals, minerals, liquids, of earth
We are earth
We are being
We are of the sky
The sun, moon, stars
A reality of how ancestors live
We are the children of earth and sky
We are the Halluci Nation
(Applause)
(Cheering)